movies with shared continuity are all
the rage these days and you've got one
movie franchise to thank learn man on
the Robert Downey jr. started action
flick debuted in 2008 no one could have
predicted the effect it would have on
movies for years afterwards Marvel
Studios and director Jon Favreau lead
the early groundwork for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe by stuffing in as
many Easter eggs and hidden references
as they could so for obsessive comic
fans the Iron Man franchise can be
summed up in one word marvelous
the dude survives Jeff Bridges
performances bad guy Obadiah Stane in
the original Iron Man may have been just
fine but everyone knows it wasn't the
role for which he'll always be known now
that distinction belongs to the dude
from The Big Lebowski as it turns out
the effects guy on Iron Man agreed and
added small tributes to the dude and
stains secret computer files which
feature fine print dialog from The Big
Lebowski
additionally the weapon stains sent to
the bad guys went on a ship called
Lebowski those details really tie the
scenes together man
or do or don't in the beginning of Iron
Man Tony Stark is kidnapped by a
terrorist group known as the ten rings
Stark's captors discussed their plan and
their secret partnership with Tony's
friends staying right in front of him
spoiling the whole movie before I can
really even begin but only if you speak
or do the national language of Pakistan
most Western audiences were none the
wiser speaking of the ten rings 10 rings
to rule them all
the first Iron Man flick would
eventually spawn a franchise but the
filmmakers didn't know that at the time
there was no way to know when or if we'd
ever really get to see the longtime
magic ring where an Iron Man villain
Mandarin make is the big screen so
instead of featuring the bad guy with
handfuls of bling the filmmakers instead
decided to pay tribute to the Mandarin
my name and the terrorists after him
which is way less cool than having a
street named after you or something at
song rings a bell still on the subject
of rings when Tony's pal Rhodey gets a
call from him on a cell phone we can
hear a very unique ringtone
that little tune is actually the theme
song for the 1966 iron man cartoon Black
Sabbath's iron man probably would have
been a little more badass but maybe a
little too on the nose Oh captain my
captain fans saw the first big hits in a
larger Marvel Cinematic Universe when
they spotted a familiar sight on Tony
Stark's workbench sitting along with
unfinished projects and other junk is
none other than Captain America's famous
patriotic shield the shield shows up
again in Iron Man 2 while a couple of
Captain America comic books also make an
appearance in a Howard Starks trunk both
movies predate the legendary super
heroes first cinematic appearance in
2011's Captain America the First Avenger
Bambi Arbogast in the comics bambina
Bambi Arbogast has been a valued Stark
employee for decades during her first
appearance in 1979 she hosts Iron Man
defeat whirlwind in the middle of her
own job interview before going on to
play a key role on a number of other
storylines you can spot Bambi played by
Margie Moore in Iron Man 2 when she's
seen working for Pepper Potts the new
CEO Stark Industries Bambi is also the
one who ends up unwittingly hiring Black
Widow for which we can all be grateful
she's also heard off-screen and Iron Man
3 reminding Pepper of her appointment
with ultra creep
Audra Killian say hello Stan spotting
Stan Lee's cameos has become a favorite
pastime for Marvel movie fans and his
appearances in the Iron Man movies are
some of the best and the first film he
shows up as Hugh Hefner with a beautiful
woman on each arm an Iron Man 2 he could
be glimpsed as a pretty uncanny stand-in
for legendary talk-show host Larry King
and an Iron Man 3 it's back to the babes
as Lee pops-up for a moment as a very
enthusiastic beauty pageant judge those
were probably all way better for his
health and some of his other Marvel
movie cameos you know like all those
times he almost got killed lady man
thing in Iron Man 3
Ellen Brent is a war veteran recruited
into audra Killians army of extremis
soldiers and spoiler alert she's killed
in an explosion after attending to get
some sensitive documents from Tony Stark
it's a fairly minor role but hardcore
Marvel fans might have recognized brands
name from the comics where she's the
ex-wife of Ted Sallis better known as
the Man Thing in the original story the
depletion is Brent is actually
responsible for sales of swampy
transformation who attacks and his
figures here at retaliation a detail not
a - in the movie with the scars on her
cheek most Marvel fans would agree
though that Ellen Brandt is a pretty
obscure reference but
still probably a good thing Iron Man 3
screenwriters didn't just call her mrs.
man-thing knapping the future of Marvel
when Tony meets with Nick Fury at the
end of Iron Man 2 to discuss the
emerging Avengers initiative viewers can
see a map marking shields locations of
interest in the background it's the kind
of thing you need to pause and zoom to
really get a good look at but it's
loaded with pretty obvious references to
the comics these spots include a
location in Africa near the fictional
Wakanda home of the Black Panther one
near Norway with the tesseract is found
by the Red Skull and Captain America the
First Avenger
another near Greenland where cap crashes
the skull ship and one in New Mexico
where Thor's hammer had just turned up
all of this was way back in 2010 before
Marvel really started rolling out its
Marvel Cinematic Universe phases so it
proves that Marvel's planning has been
tighter than Black Widows outfit all
along hulking out during the same
meeting between Stark and fury and Iron
Man 2 particularly observant viewers can
see a television in the background tuned
to a news report being delivered live
from the campus of Culver University not
coincidentally Culver is where the Hulk
faced off against Thunderbolt Ross and
Emil Blonsky in the Incredible Hulk
which puts the events of that film as
happening on the same timeframe as Iron
Man 2 in the Marvel movie timeline but
still a few years before Tony would
deliver the oil Hulk Buster jackhammer
the Hulk's face thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to see
more videos like the one you just saw
and leave us a comment to let us know
which Hidden Iron Man secret was your
favorite